[Musique]
bonjour bonjour l'humanité qu'est ce que
vous avez dans les bras qu'est-ce que
vous avez amené leur nouveau bébé du
monde d'un petit avion un petit agneau
qui vient d'où du pays basque de tarbes
est ce tardait oui celui-là on ne va pas
le tuer on va pas trouver d'être beau il
est venu pour mener sa vie maintenant un
peu à la campagne près de chez vous il à
reprendre verts eelv a mis nos routes
est bien aussi adorable que ce soit
maïté il faut bien dire que on en mange
hélas depuis toujours depuis très très
longtemps voilà il ya une ue pascal vial
agneaux c'est la saison maintenant des
agneaux et les moments de l'année où
voilà voilà alors on va pas faire un
cours d'histoire bien sûr mais là si on
recherche on peut s'apercevoir que
l'agneau ça a été le mets préférés des
civilisations très anciennes et ses
présences faire c'est vrai il est
attaché à la fuite d'egypte des juifs
bien entendu dans ses vieux bien sûr que
ces vieux et c'est pour ça que l'ailier
a une idée d'innocence a eu l'idée de
sacrifice sacrifice de jésus aura par
contre des gestes des agneaux mais nous
on va pas le sacrifier
on va pas le sacrifier on va laisser
aller courir et puis on va faire un plat
avec d'autres agneaux dont on imaginera
qui viennent on ne sait d'où voilà le
green n'a jamais été comme ça alors
qu'est ce que vous allez vous faire
quand même tendance à evian on va faire
lannion à la broche qui est excellent et
on va faire les épaule d'agneau farcie
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on commence on
va le faire revenir la broche parce que
c'est mon année les cheminées voilà et
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
pas grand chose aujourd'hui il nous faut
de l'huile avec du thym du laurier
honnart vous avez fait nous expliquez
moi de plus en ligue 1 alors moi j'ai
mis du temps là dedans oui et c'est le
goût de chacun
oui on peut mettre du ser soler du
romarin ce qu'on veut l'on venait de
combien de temps faut-il laisser dans
l'huile une bonne journée une bonne
journée à main serré et ça servira à
enduire la carcasse de ce bel agneaux
voilà
car vous avez prévu quelques haricots
pas beaucoup je trouve oui mais ça c'est
pour les bretons l'appétit aujourd'hui
il faut venger avec l'agneau une offre
un avantage c'est justement de près et
l'agneau qu'est ce que vous avez vu
faire maintenant et bien on va l'enfiler
renfiler c'est gagner on va l'embaucher
le mettre à cuire c'est difficile maïté
non il faut le faire il faut attacher
les parties soit chez les femmes avec un
fil de fer ou la sq une ficelle ça brûle
graisse pour tout va bien et vous me
direz oui bien sûr voilà je dévisse et
fermin effet que je fixe bien à
l'enfoncer beaucoup vous allez vérifier
si c'est bien fait parce que vous savez
je suis pas une spécialiste défenseurs
et c'est tout mais la côte et j'espère
que j'essaierai après nous et variés et
alors que vous lui fait alors non en
habit jaune avec votre petit eric séduit
les d'herbe
on en met dedans et dehors on est
partout et parlant remettra un tweeter
nouveau tri sur wii
la vague ça brûle nord ça que je
voudrais pas de lui le partout les
tourner oui voilà le port ce qu'on veut
sur payés en mur mais c'est l'autre côté
aussi on le vernis la bon et après ça
n'y a plus qu'à le mettre ces lois ont
d'abord donné leur et nous restera plus
qu'à le mettre à cuire dans la cheminée
bien sûr voilà il faudra le quai combien
de temps maïté a alors là il faut
regarder
oui mais minimum trois heures de temps
parce que tant que ça oui parce qu'il
faut pas que ce soit un feu vif et il
faut que l'accusé quand même et oui
voilà quand même une chaise oui bien
confortable parce que vous avez
l'intention de faire tourner pendant
trois heures de temps encore de la
manivelle je vous donnerai bouquin j'ai
le temps de rêver à l'histoire
millénaire de l'agneau et vous allez
faire quoi maintenant pour percevoir moi
je vais farcir vos épaules
je suppose que vous l'avez des os et
maïté pratiquement politiquement alors
raconté ou ce que vous allez en faire
tant d'enjeux tournoi toujours voulu
m'amuser comme une petite folle
voilà mon épaule est très belle je vais
finir mon rachis où j'ai mis vingt
treize oignons échalotes
j'ai mélangé des poivrons
et tout pour que ça donne un bon goût la
voilà yen à c j'ai mis toutes les
couleurs pour égayer la faire voilà et
je vais mettre ça accueillir dans la
poêle je ne vais ni salé poivré pour la
bonne raison que ma ventrèche seul un
petit peu là les allées lumière mondiaux
pendant ce temps je l'abats d'hygiène
encore un peu vous croyez tournée
badigeonner résidence à ce tournoi
badigeonne oui je rajoute un peu de tout
à l'ère blanc exactement
voilà mon épaule est bien belle je
l'aimais la salle aimé la proie vrai
pendant que ça ça cuit
voilà ce la salle et je la bois rouge
wall un petit peu l'intérieur et
l'extérieur effet là
séduire savary chenil oui je crois moi
je trouve que c'est bon et bien où je
viendrai avec des jolies l'oeil ça vous
plaît très bien que c'est très bien bon
moi j'ai ma farce pratiquement qui va
aller pour la bonne raison qu'elle va
finir de cuire dans mon épaule
voilà je vais la flambée ça va l'aider à
finir là c'est pas mauvais ce que vous
êtes en train voilà mon avis sur
regarder ça je vois ça de loin
impeccable je crois que ça va être
plutôt bon au moins on fait ce qu'on
veut et ça finit le cuir voilà je vais
faire si mon épaule
alors là enfants terme il faut pas
mettre beaucoup et c'est comme dans
métro
on a des ennuis maïté ça va faire pour
qu une personne se plaint la caisse à la
wii ce que vous faites l'épaule moi j'en
ai pour mon mari et moi oui c'est ce qui
me semble et paris autrement trois
personnes si quelqu'un se sacrifie pour
l'os mais vous allez me dire pour les
parisiens ya là pour 6,6 sur un an
les parisiens les produits marchent pas
beaucoup les en ligne ils ont leurs lits
y manger la mienne là je suis pas comme
un boucher essentielle en train de
mayotte et ça comme une paupiette new
way et près pareil et puis je vous
assure c'est pas facile parce que c'est
mou comme tout bon j'arrête pour ça
voilà
vous allez écrire ça comment au four ça
devrait pas que mauvais avec céline on
les remet ça dedans ça vous êtes bon là
on ne rajoute rien ni grave ni rien du
tout je vais me le mettre gentiment au
four voilà c'est assez gras la nuit ya
pas besoin de mettre gradins au nord
c'est bon rien du tout bien ça les bleus
poivre et voilà combien avant la demi
heure et une dernière plus il va très
bien
mais pendant ce temps je crois que vous
pourrez revenir voir l'agneau parce que
et bien il a bien dorées il est
magnifique il est super bien mais il est
prêt ah oui un week end à la campagne
maïté vous imaginez ça c'est sûr a mis
un joli agneaux comme ça vous mettez ça
sur la table vous régaler vos amis
foudre avec des flageolets bien et
regardez moi cette petite que vous savez
de cet excellent là que d'un lieu bien
sûr by croustillants comme c'est d'abord
puis sur la braise et ses délicieux la
démence a cessé ben voilà alors il faut
être combien l'a6 ou vite une dizaine à
la une dizaine on se met au coin de la
cheminée
on tourne à tour de rôle parce que de
moi tout seul il fait chaud oui bien sûr
alors on se relaie et puis on fait ça et
c'est délicieux et il est heureux mais
même dans la montagne 400 dans la
montagne quand ils se font fuir sa au
four parce que ça c'est un petit agneau
de tardets celui-là il vient de tardets
la montagne c'est un agneau qui n'a été
que le lait de sa maman dont sa maman a
passé tout l'été dans la montagne c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont si beaux si léger et
facile à digérer
alors vous vous savez ça mais pour toute
la france et pour nos amis aussi bien au
delà de la france l'un dollars dette
c'est dans les pyrénées atlantiques
presque à la frontière d'espagne en
algérie mais cela sent bon et puis il
nous reste à voir comment sera cette
poule farcie comme ça mais j'y pense
mais était il faudrait peut-être prévoir
un légume pour l'accompagner oui bon on
va faire des ricoh et tout ce que vous
avez mis là c'est pour faire des
haricots en gras
oui mais c'est bon et c'est des haricots
amélioré alors il vous faut quoi
et oui il me faudrait 25 du terrain du
laurier de l'ail de l'oignon des petits
piments d'espelette ben la ventrèche la
voilà avec la couenne que ceux sortis un
petit peu de cerfeuil du
derick ho que j'ai déjà mis à tremper et
on ignore oui parce que c'est des
haricots commenge en hiver si cette
théorie t on les a après voilà mais là
ils sont secs encore par quoi méditer
par le gain se les faire revenir
l'oignon dans quoi dans la grèce j'ai
mis ma poêle à chauffer avec de la
graisse de canard à rien entendu bien
entendu bien chaude et vous le trouverez
à la main cas parfois être qu'elle ait
inventé
non parce que ça en cuisant oui parce
que là on va l'avoir j'aurais dû mettre
les haricots tout de suite mais comme
ceux des petits haricots pionniers
draper ils vont peut-être qu un navire
de temps alors il faut mieux faire
fondre nous avions un petit peu pour
alors c'est on va tout mettre en même
temps d'avoir aidé à ses amplis qu'est
ce que vous allez ajouter
pendant que l'oignon puis de la solderie
feu je veux mettre mes haricots camp de
l'australienne de l'eau
là y'a rien du tout dans de l'eau qu'il
est bouillante et brillante parce que là
je vais saler et poivrer mais là on seul
sa défense connais mes deux derniers
vraiment subi de la ventrèche et patrice
ali et si on y met 10 confient sur lee
mais beaucoup de bonnes choses rien au
piano pour le seul alors devrait
préparer une coin de la rue oui là le
velvet est sur scène deux choses la
toile je vais la mettre avec le ter et
le laurier lacroix ne voyait un peu la
même qu'hier on vous la mettez où ils
vous l'année que naulleau et les admire
le met dans l'eau je vais y mettre une
branche de l'offrir inside oui une
feuille la branche ce serait un peu trop
one à le dire or mes démons tous compris
ça va pas très bien et sans tricherie
très bien nous aurons ensuite le teint
avons bouclé la jeune effet les fuyards
intelligent après des piments
d'espelette
ces forces n'ont msa bonhomme en mousse
avant les monos saveurs en'or comme on
est mais bon je vais pouvait maintenir
un petit peu ce rpi
on l'a du joli c'est dommage de s'en
priver m formé comme ça parce qu'on le
sort ou en le barça c'est au bout de
chaque heure oui je vais faire envoyer
omonia olivet
impeccable prévient va bien parfait je
faire des petits lardons les piments
j'en ai assez alors les petits lardons
dans la poitrine de porc [ __ ] voilà
toujours pareil lui l'art mais qu on va
être même un terme à jo dans les
haricots ça ne gâche pas non plus une
cuisse et les traînards non plus saleh
paraît mais comme non veulent marcher
avec des pôles d'areva
oui là alors si je voulais refaire
revenir un oignon des panneaux de vie
voilà
et là y'a tout oui voilà
et je vais tout mettre la de dare dare
mes haricots
oui c'est ce que j'appelle moi de l'aeri
cobian amélioré en phase qu'avec tout ça
dedans il est bien meilleur on veut on
peut pas faire moins 8 après la super g
et rick oui si on met moins c'est pas
bon ça sent déjà bon alors oui vous ne
sentez pas monsieur lavaud sand est un
symbole sexuel là et combien de temps
maintenant là vous savez ça va cuire
vite et quand même là dans une heure et
puis il faut les regarder parce qu'il
faut pas qu'il savait pas c'est que le
lien pour les surveiller et c'est tout
et après ça il n'y aura plus qu'à
présenter nos plats exactement alors
voyez on à l'épaule d'agneau farcie à
griller avec des règles bonheur voilà
et puis là et là le gigot d'inca cuit
dans la cheminée la suite à l'achat la
branche sur le trail des beltran jouit
également avec des haricots sur lesquels
on appartenait au dernier moment un peu
de cerfeuil et on a toujours d'autres à
nyon très bien sûr et heureusement pour
la touche et il est beau vous mangez
peut-être moins un petit peu de ville
marié dit palin est le lien moi je
croyais qu'il a fallu un but tu peux
devait vous et moi petit bout allez
allez vite
non j'ai à parfaire finale avant même
ses mandats et mal en pis alors à vous
d'essayer si vous avez un joli agneau ou
bien si vous achetez chez le boucher
soit une épaule soit un gigot vous ferez
des choses délicieuses
bon appétit à bientôt bon appétit et
merci or vraiment petit agneau
[Musique]